it's from the new york post we're
actually pulling up the new post twitter
facebook
sensor post over hunter biden expose
i wonder if we're going to get shut off
if like youtube will pull this trend out
find out
let's keep reading both twitter and
facebook took
extraordinary censorship measures
against the post on wednesday over its
exposes about hunter biden's emails
and leveled baseless accusations that
the reports used
hacked materials the suppression effort
came
despite presidential candidate joe
biden's campaign merely denying
that he had anything on his official
schedules about meeting a ukrainian
energy executive in 2015
along with zero claims that his son's
computer had been hacked
the post's primary twitter account was
locked as of 2 20 p.m
wednesday because it's articles about
the messages obtained from biden's
laptop broke the social network's rules
against quote
distribution of hacked material
according to an email the post received
from twitter
twitter also blocked users from sharing
the link to the post
indicating that hunter biden introduced
joe biden to the ukrainian businessman
calling the link potentially harmful
now that is a fat load of crap harmful
link to the new york post
that's a whole lot harmful to whom to
joe biden
exactly right yeah we saw uh it was andy
stone
he worked for the democrats he was on
the senate majority pack he was on he
worked for the democratic congressional
campaign committee
and now he works for facebook and he
said we're gonna suppress this
we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna
suppress this story straight up and all
these journalists are are well
anti-journalists sorry
these people are depraved man no joke
like utter depravity
they just want power it's not good
enough to be a journalist you have to be
you have to be not a journalist you have
to be it is not good enough
to simply be a journalist you must
actively be anti-journalist
yeah that's what they're doing what
they're doing here is they've lost the
battle of ideas they've lost the upper
hand they've lost the high ground
and what they've done is instead of
trying to change people's minds and
opinions and ideas they change the rules
of the game
yeah it's like a little kid slamming the
table and screaming and flipping the
board over and over again because you're
winning in chess i think
you know trump whatever he posts on
twitter people will like mirror his
account sometimes they'll make a new
account just whatever trump
tweets out they'll tweet it out and
they've been banning those accounts oh
yeah they leave trump up
so it seems like they're not anti-trump
they're just like excessively
authoritarian they're anti-trump but
they would ban trump if they could but
it would cause too many problems for
them but it's too much like hearsay like
i'm just feeling like this is bit gonna
be
true i know how it goes being an admin a
social media admin you have total
control over what you want to ban
yeah trump's tweets will get flagged and
they'll claim he's breaking the rules
like
my favorite was when they were like
trump needs to be banned for for
breaking the rules on
violent or threatening posts because he
threatened north korea
i'm like oh well hold on a minute like
there's a difference between i mean i i
agree
trump should chill out when threatening
other countries but he's also the
president the commander-in-chief of the
armed forces
and if he's making a statement about the
might of america versus our adversaries
can we ban that could you could you
imagine if twitter does do that
what are they going to do with trump
after after the presidency is over
whether it's you know hopefully have you
seen it but four years from now what
happens then they just going to ban him
out right after that or they
it's too much of a um cash cow for them
have you seen the ryan long
comedy skit he did on this the
journalists one month after the election
they're like all sweaty and like
freaking out like what do we write about
and someone's like
we can write about how trump no no trump
is just a guy now
right that's where we're headed they're
doomed well they'll just go back to
doing what they did before
which is just return regurgitating
without any question or skepticism
everything that the democrats hand them
to produce yup dude the the
news in this country is alive and well
right here temple that's right i mean
kind of
correct conservatives do very little
journalism
very little they mostly do commentary
and response
they they chase after the narrative put
out by the left so the left is framing
everything
now the left has gotten so absurd with
their framing
that now people are starting to go what
and the new york post is is not uh on
the left and they do journalists i'm
just saying
there's a tendency of most of the
sourcing
and publishing and statements being made
that are like definitive news stories
i don't mean factual i mean like this is
a news story and here's what happened
it's it's left bias absolutely left wise
and then you end up with uh rating
agencies media bias fact check news
guard
um a bunch of these websites that they
base what's centrist off of
establishment left-leaning media yeah
there's a lot
i want to read this line here from from
twitter they say in line with our hacked
materials policy
as well as our approach to blocking urls
we are taking action to block any links
to or images of the material in question
on twitter a twitter spokesperson told
the post in a statement
the company said it took the step
because of the uh the lack of
authoritative reporting
on where the materials included in uh
where the materials included the post
story originated
they they said they originated from from
a laptop so uh for those that don't know
the story you guys
did you guys hear the story yet or we
did we read the story talked about a
little bit let's talk about some more
though maybe i missed something
so this guy at a repair shop somebody
comes in and gives them a water logged
computer
doesn't work so he copies the hard drive
and then
you know tries to fix it i guess he
couldn't fix it and eventually uh dude
never shows up
he doesn't he couldn't identify hunter
biden as the dude
the computer had beau biden foundation
on it so apparently he gave a copy to
rudy giuliani's lawyer
and then he gave a copy to the feds
apparently he gave the copy to rudy
giuliani's lawyer a year ago
did you hear that oh no i wonder if
they've been sitting on it until
what month is it oh yeah is it october
yeah it's october what do you know
so look i'll say it straight up dirty
politics however
if it's true it's true indeed yeah i
mean there is a picture with him laying
in bed with a crock pipe in his mouth
theoretically hypothetically so it could
be a weed it looks like it yeah we were
debating this earlier because it's
it looks like there's resin in the bowl
it's a cracker which could be just
thc resin you know it's a good reason
it's a it's a correct but it also could
be freebasing
so you've smoked wheat out of a bowl
right yeah it's got the was it choke on
it yeah
you shot the carb or whatever yeah yeah
yeah yeah this thing has got his mouth
does not have then after you oh it
doesn't have one
no it doesn't need one correct you can
smoke weed out of a pipe without a carb
on it
sure i don't look i don't know if you're
smoking crack you're probably a
connoisseur of some kind so you're
getting the right pipe
he's got the right pipe the question i
had about this too because we were
talking about a little before is like
isn't hunter biden rich he's getting 83
000 a month from this crooked barisma
deal
and and he he he opts for crack instead
of that sweet colombian
they're from scranton dude that's right
they are
working they're just regular salt of the
earth people
hey he's not above smoking crack just to
be joe biden's new thing
don't go supporting this wall street
people these park avenue people support
me and my family we are a salt of the
earth we are from scranton we are not
even above smoking
crack yo well there was a there's a
celebrity on them
so now that we're shifting from the very
serious like death to free speech in
this country
yeah uh but we actually got the story we
got we got we got to follow us up check
this out
cocaine pipe and white powdery substance
found in hunter biden's rental car in
2016 from the washington examiner
see a police report said that joe
biden's son hunter biden returned a
rental car in arizona that contained a
cocaine pipe
days before the 2016 presidential
election according to a new report
hunter biden's first name is robert also
left credit cards drivers licenses
okay
yeah so is there is look we got this
photo now it shows joe biden's son with
like a crack pipe in his mouth is
this is not even the serious news the
serious news is that joe biden lied
apparently i gotta say apparently we'd
be very careful he'll get a presidential
election but
the email suggests that the ukrainian
prison businessman from
marisma the third most powerful man said
thank you for
you know giving the opportunity to thank
you for like bringing me to dc and
giving the opportunity to meet with you
know your dad or whatever or something
and spend time with him
it was like poor english so it's kind of
confusing i saw i think bloomberg said
being granted the opportunity doesn't
mean he actually met
yeah but have you liked that thanks for
the opportunity that's what you say
thanks for the opportunity
appreciate it it was great right that's
weird yeah what do you mean thanks for
the opportunity to come to your house
it's too bad we didn't do it that's
weird right i i
i'm glad you sort of switched back to
the important news because we should say
one thing like
it's obvious on our body and dealing
with drug addiction drug addiction is
very serious many of us
almost all of us know somebody's
struggling with drug addiction it's
generally not a laughing matter and you
know what prayers up
hunter biden hopefully one day he can
get that under control right
and so but what the real story let's not
be distracted by the crack bites
the real story is possibly him peddling
influence and connections with his
father getting paid to do it all along
the way
it's interesting the story that's being
blocked is specifically about
uh this this businessman meeting his dad
yeah so this is really interesting i
think the house judiciary uh
committee house judiciary gop says
twitter has blocked users from tweeting
the link to the new york post store and
hunter biden
so we put it on our website for you to
read and share love it and it links to
the republicans judiciary.house.gov
and it's the story so is twitter now
going to blocka.gov
that would be very very interesting yeah
it doesn't seem to be beyond them at
this point
yeah so so let me let me break down for
everybody who doesn't understand what's
happening here what the seriousness of
this
of the story it's a viral video where
joe biden says
i wanted you know i'll paraphrase i want
to get this prosecutor in ukraine fired
so i use i think it was a billion dollar
loan guarantee the u.s is going to loan
ukraine a billion dollars
and so we went to the prime minister and
said if you don't fire him you're not
getting the money
and the guy says you can't you can't do
that only the president can he goes call
the president ask him
so and then he's like sure enough six
hours later he's like i'm getting ready
to leave
you know son of a bee guy got fired
everyone's laughing and clapping
the first response i had to that was
because you got the right saying he's
he's manipulating the speak to protect
his son because his son was on the board
of this company
the prosecutor was investigating that
company then you get the left saying
it's not true
the eu thought he was corrupt they want
to get rid of him as well my response is
uh why why why is the vice president
going to any country
and bribing them to interfere in
internal affairs for these other
countries
like that to me on its own is kind of
like
that's true i don't like that idea that
the us goes to foreign countries and
says we'll give you a billion dollars to
fire your prosecutor
do you think that that's a new evolution
in american foreign
though right no that's so so my
understanding is typically the way it
works is we go there we say listen to
you
we're in america you get rid of this
prosecutor we'll give you a billion
dollars
you don't take the billion dollars maybe
things get a little bad maybe your
auntie has an accident you know what i'm
saying
and then sure enough you don't take the
money and then protest forms and then
where you don't get that anti-aircraft
you know sales go through that you
thought you were gonna get you can't buy
the self-defense
you know weaponry that you thought you
were gonna get you don't get the loan
from the imf or the world bank that you
thought that you were gonna get
you don't get the investment in a port
or an airport or whatever it is that you
thought that you might get
we've been doing this kind of crap right
there's confessions of an economic hit
yeah i was going to mention that
there's three steps the first is
economic if they don't fall for it then
you send in
people to try and assassinate the leader
and i thought that was the last one
that's the second one if you can't
assassinate theater then you were
yep yep yeah yeah i remember watching
that so what was that like he was like
ciao it's great yeah you read his book
check him out on youtube so
it works even on the individual level
the first thing anyone tries to do is
bribe you
if they can if they can give you some
cash and you'll do their bidding it's
the easiest way to get it done
otherwise they're going to start
pressuring you and threatening you and
your family if they can't deal with you
and you won't solve
and the problem can't be solved they off
you and if they can't then they go to
war literally and so
i just mean like in iraq for instance
they went to war because they couldn't
get saddam
they tried to kill them they couldn't do
it so they you know they we in the
united states
marched in for no reason our
representatives yeah
yes we the people so look look look i
understand this is a normal process
and i'm not saying it's a good thing i'm
saying it's it's routine where the us
says like we got a billion dollars why
don't you take it and
fire this guy and they took it they
fired the guy here's the crazy bit about
this
the guy was investigating barisma now
some outlets
argue he wasn't actually there was an
open investigation it was inactive
and i'm kind of like so you admit
there's an investigation like the status
of the investigation is less relevant to
me because it could be inactive because
it went cold
i don't know it could be inactive
because the dude started cooperating or
because it let them out there's a
million reasons it could be an active
or a billion yeah yeah infinite i have
no idea
all i know is they opened investigation
it became an active for some reason
joe biden says this guy wasn't
investigating barisma
that's why they wanted to fire him so
hunter biden joe biden's son
is on the board of this company and we
we believe based on all the evidence
specifically
because he's selling his father's
influence
it's like you can't give joe biden money
but you can give hunter money
you give hunter that that you know
eighty three thousand dollar a month
contract all of a sudden joe biden's
doing your favors and get rid of that
prosecutor
that's the allegation here's the best
part joe biden says
this prosecutor shoken victor shuken was
not investigating
this corruption at barisma that's why we
wanted him gone
and so son of a bee right that's what he
said guy got fired
guess what new prosecutor comes in
clears our chess give all wrongdoing
huh that's weird that's weird i thought
the prosecutor was supposed to be
investigating him
turns out the new prosecutor came in no
problems you're free to go buddy
zlatchevsky comes back to the ukraine
working like like no big deal
then in 2018 during the trump
administration new charges get brought
back
zlatchevsky flees to monaco under trump
i'm not saying there's a correlation
like between trump and this i'm just
telling you
if joe biden's excuse is legitimate that
he was supposed to be investigating this
guy
and the new prosecutor found no wrong
doing then joe biden got a prosecutor
fired for not going after an innocent
man
that's that's the official story of joe
biden now i think most of us assume joe
biden's probably crooked especially with
these emails
and what he was really doing was cutting
a favor for his son who was getting the
cash
his son's getting paid there was an
email saying thanks for introducing me
i i think it was like almost a little
bit less than a year later
joe biden flies out there fire the guy
as soon as he got fired
and when you say they're investigating
charisma what were they investigating
them
for zlatski so so uh i think his name is
micholo's
slavchevsky was the founder of brezma is
corrupt he's been accused of a bunch of
things
and uh along with the work he did it
you know it it burisma is the periphery
what barismo was involved in is directly
related to what zlatchevsky was doing
so shokun argued that he was actually
looking at the executives
of this company as well because of their
involvement
listen throw that all aside it's it's
just it's got to be said
why in the ever living is is joe biden's
son who doesn't speak ukrainian who who
has no experience in the energy sector
getting paid 83
000 a month to work be on the board of
this company right
biden that's why his name and then one
of the stories from the new york post
it looks like in the email i say it
looks like because i got to be very
careful here
he's saying like you know once people
realize like our guy
and what he says our guys coming in
the new york post is asserting that he
was using his his
dad joe biden's visit to influent to
gain more money
like going to these companies and saying
hey my dad's coming
you got a pony up we can't tell him you
know joe what to do
but you know i love see ladies if you
can find this story yeah
it's from politico magazine about the
corruption of the biden family and it's
from a few years ago
about how biden's brother his kids have
all just come
come into all this great money you know
i was having a conversation
earlier today and i i thought of
something i think i think donald trump's
got a lot of problems
i think joe biden's got a lot of
problems and i said you know what i'd
rather take the guy
who's losing money trying to get
reelected then take the guy who's trying
to get elected to make money
you found it yeah oh look at this oh
snap and we go baby biden
inc over his decades in office middle
class joe's family fortunes
have closely tracked his political
career august 2nd 2019.
look at that they talk about his brother
they talk about his son
purchasing a firm you know what what
what's what's the
what's that firm they had what was that
called rosemont seneca
all that magic money flying what else
get into politics that's right
joe biden has been in politics for 47
years 47 years and he made himself very
wealthy
and his brother would you say salt of
the earth from scranton right exactly
what's he worth now several million
dollars how is it that he
had to even pay three million dollars in
taxes in 2017.
like why what is how where's that income
coming from and why
you get that's the name of the game dude
he he he
he you get into politics you get the
power then you pedal that influence
first and and army yeah exactly of
course you get the
political position right i think about
could you imagine
you know like imagine this scenario
somebody gets elected to say like you
know
senate or whatever and then gets
appointed to uh
like some some administration position
maybe like secretary of state and they
launch a non-profit foundation
i'm tracking that's like and it brings
in hundreds of millions of dollars and
and donations from all of these foreign
countries
while the person whose name is on
the nonprofit foundation no one would
ever do that it's like the secretary of
state or something
could you amen let me ask you though for
those that are listening
if i told you that we had a secretary of
state
who also had a non-profit that received
foreign donations from much of different
countries
what would you think about that we got
to give it a hypothetical name like the
clinton
foundation yeah yeah that's a a good
hypothetical name yeah we'll call it the
clinton foundation so just
hypothetically
if if the secretary of state uh hillary
clinton
hypothetically yeah uh uh rana found a
foundation the clinton foundation was
receiving money from a bunch of foreign
countries
while they were the secretary of state i
mean that just reeks of corruption
doesn't it
dude involvement with like uh
sydney blumenthal who was has this
company global osprey solutions they
wanted to set up weapons deals in libya
and so hillary was like yeah sid in her
emails came out with her stuff with
sydney who's been advising the clinton
since the 90s
yeah we'll we'll we'll get you guys set
up in libya when we when we go in with
our guys
then she tells barack what's going to
libya as the secretary of state
sets up her buddy with weapons deals
arms contracts we
came we saw he died i mean joe biden
supposedly paid three some million
dollars in taxes in 2017.
if you've got a good cpa whatever you
know that's tens of millions of dollars
that he's earning now people say
trump is using the presidency to trade
up financially
yeah to enrich himself dude's got a
golden toilet
right so how is it though that joe biden
makes it to the point where he's earning
tens of millions of dollars to pay three
million dollars in taxes in one year
how is that not the whole time enriching
himself through his political you gotta
you gotta ask yourself now nancy pelosi
uh her her personal net worth is
actually i think in the in the in the uh
eight digits
but her husband is extremely wealthy so
her married net worth is like 200
million
yikes but still you got to ask yourself
how is that somebody runs for congress
their salary is 170k per year now
they're millionaires
it's book deals a lot of times and like
speaking deals which is exactly
leveraging their political office to
make for sure
but think about this you could you could
write a book
and then a pack could buy up you know 10
000 copies for distribution i bet that
never happens
oh yeah it literally does happen there's
there's
rooms filled with box boxes full of
books somewhere there's no one ever
around
yeah and it's left in right it's
republican and democrat yeah
i think trump's very very different
though and it's really funny to me i saw
a post from somebody and they were like
there's no
what was socks the cat is that the cat's
name what was the dog's name the clinton
head or something i don't know
barney no it's like bushes they were
like there's no fido there's no dogs
there's no
there's no roses in the rose garden
they've been ripped out by this you know
like literally insulted melania for
being a foreigner and it was like what's
happened to our country and i'm like
is that what you were worried about this
whole time like there's no dog at the
white house the roses the roses are gone
is that what you were
because i was worried about the fact
that we blew up like a bunch of kids in
a foreign country you know that was
freaking me out the whole time like i'm
sitting there like why can't what's
going on why are we doing this
robot assassins on one hand not a dog in
the yard
another i don't know if the white house
doesn't have crap in the lawn is it
really the white house
i'm gonna go back one more time this
2017 taxes thing because i'm stuck on
this yeah man
he got elected the end of 2016 trump did
took off at the beginning of 2017 right
as part of taking office he's supposed
to move all his money away not make any
money whatever
he gets paid 400 whatever grant to be
the president but he gives out all that
money away
so didn't we demand that he make no
money in 2017 wasn't that the demand
right off the bat
and now the guy reports he didn't make
any money so he's not paying any taxes
like
how is that the story not you it's not
him but he pay taxes he paid a million
dollars in 26 millions and millions of
other kinds of taxes this is a
ridiculous thing this is what's shocking
to me
i think the new york times has there's a
clear case for
uh libel for trump that story they put
out about his taxes opens with trump and
only paid 750 in taxes and then halfway
down it says trump actually paid
a total of 5.2 million but his liability
was only 750
but he did pay millions so why in the if
in the beginning they said he only paid
750
the one line people read and x out but
they knew that wasn't true and later on
said the total payment was actually in
the millions
isn't that proving they lied and they
knew they lied
they presented a fact one fact
without the rest of the facts which
actually are no no no no it is it is
factually untrue that trump only paid
750. that is not correct
oh i see it should have said he owed
750. he was liable
for 7.50 there we go the opening line of
the new york times story said
trump paid 750. if you actually read the
story they said
trump actually paid a million in 2016
and 4.2 in 2017
but after uh calculating his losses was
only liable for 7.50
trump let the irs hold that money for
all future payments
meaning trump paid the irs millions of
dollars yes and then when it turned out
his liability was low because of losses
he said just
just keep the money and you know we'll
apply it later so trump paid millions of
dollars
well i guess it's factually true if you
pay a million dollars you've also paid
750.
yeah there it is yep that's that's the
dirty tricks of the anti-journalists
reminds me of rick and morty i don't
know if you've seen it where you've seen
it i love that the one where where
morty's in the simulation and he's like
he gets asked like what's nine times
eight and he's like
it's at least 45. that's right it is at
least
45. that's exactly what it is trump paid
you know you know that trump paid one
dollar in taxes last year
one dollar another 740 on top of that
and
and well after that he paid millions and
millions you know but that one dollar
he did yeah he paid one dollar and two
and three and four and five and six
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time